you know what it's one of the toughest
things to do in life is learning could
it take advice from let me explain to
you what this means this is not one of
these Roerig will get the right advisor
mentor life will change
no I'm never I never put weight on who's
given the advice think about it this way
the world is filled with wisdom how come
only small percentage wins at the
highest level is that the person given
the advice or is it a person receiving
the advice hmm
what do you mean let me explain if today
in my mind I want to convince myself to
leave my family
I can't intentionally take any advice
given by anybody and turn it in the
direction of what I want to hear not
because the advice that people are
giving me like you can sit and talk to
somebody and somebody's gonna say such
as you'd want to Romero never marital
issues and somebody says well you know
one of the things is one thing list 99%
of stuff they say is about you staying
together the one person they say no the
only thing if you only want to hear that
1% that's the only thing you'll take so
it's not the person giving the advice
I'm naturally kind of kid she can you
see let me go a little layer deeper than
that here's another thing that's
confusing I got a call the other day
from one of our guys that I worked with
him and she said hey Pat I got a call
from somebody that's in their 70s and
they were giving me advice and it was
very confusing I said tell me why I was
confusing to you because it was advice
being given for me to slow down I said
how did you process that and she's just
I couldn't understand it I said would
tell me more I won't I'm not given any
feedback I'm just trying to see what she
said she says one why are they giving us
this advice - do you think they're
giving me the advice from their current
situation or do you think they're giving
it from their failures that they made
and it didn't work out for them or do
you think they're giving me the advice
from where I'm at today
when she started asking me those
questions guess what's the first thing I
thought about I said she knows how to
take advice but does that make sense
like she is she's weighing it all out
and she's processing get insane
why would this person say some let me
explain something to you even people
with this so think about it this way let
you say I'm 73 and I'm worth a couple
hundred million dollars and you come and
ask hey what does it feel like to have a
couple hundred million dollars and I say
that's not what you think it is it's
really not what you think it is
and you're telling all really you were
planning on working your tail up to go
make a couple of million dollars now
it's not really what it's you know
you're like a little confused but then
as you peel the layers of the onion you
start realizing this person may have
just lost somebody in their lives maybe
they just got a news a month ago that
their son who became a great lawyer
started making a half a million dollar
your income and went to the right school
everything in this person put so many
years into the son but he's got a
cocaine addiction that they can't drop
or a pain medication addiction they can
you don't know the whole story into a
device very rarely will a 72 year old or
63 year old or an 81 year old in that
situation give you advice that's best
needed for you at the 32 year old age
because they've been disconnected from
32 for 40 years
um someone I think they've been
disconnected from you for 40 years so
they're only given you advices from a 72
year old to a 32 whatever your ages you
know third thirty Twitter's scroll that
call me let you say she's in the early
thirties that advice is only being
coming from
not thinking about where you're at so
for me I talk to a lot people say Pat
don't you think it's a bad idea all
these people you're talking some of them
are mops or some of them are this I'm
not worried about who's giving me the
advice I'm concerned about fixing how I
process the it but who gives me advice
people give me by every day I watch TV
CNN Fox MSNBC ESPN radio books magazines
about it given advice what does that
have to do with me that doesn't know I'm
taking everybody's advice but if you
have made up your mind on a shortcut or
a way out or a way that you don't want
to do the work I guarantee you your
advice you receive from everybody around
you will be exactly what you want to
receive and then one day you're gonna
look back and say dammit I screwed up
look at this entire entire Antonia Brown
situation Oh Pittsburgh they don't take
care of the people that that
roethlisberger coach this coach dad he
leaves I want to be a writer I want to
be a Raider helmet helmet I don't like
the helmet fine use this helmet and in
Jon Gruden calls Avada John what's going
on there do you just want to play or
what you guys will be be the Raider I
want to be Raider what do you want to do
and then BOOM Instagram post release me
and then they release him then he does a
video oh my gosh Graham are they release
me they released me and video goes viral
he uses joong geun is recording then
Bill Belichick comes and picks him up
why Bill Belichick knows how to work
with Randy Moss on those kinds of
players he picks him up and then he goes
to New England then he goes to New
England Patriots first game scores a
touchdown then he's got some personal
life allegations then the Patriots drop
him you know what happens after the
Patriots problem when Belichick drops
you that is not good reputation because
Bill Belichick everybody follows him
what he does is what everybody does so
if the guy everybody is respecting drops
you there is a statement being made so
why did that happen again
who is Brown taking advice from
and how is he processing the advice I
have a lot of people on my family my
love and that love me I don't take their
advice just because you love me that
doesn't qualify as advice that that's
not the qualification so look I know
you've been watching this broker look
what is the message you're trying to
convey to me the message I'm trying to
convey to you is the call I got this
week from one of our best leaders and
the company that I'm working she's so
brilliant I am so impressed by the fact
that she questioned the advice being
given to her based on the face of her
life she's currently in that is wisdom
at a young age and I think everybody can
run from this to think about at what age
to take advice from who and what level
they're at it's a complete different
story hope that made sense to you if
you're confused don't worry about it go
watch a cat video or motivational video
or go watch a prank video to kind of get
yourself back into being normal but if
this makes sense to you
on how and who to take advice from then
good for you my job was done with
today's video aside from that I'm out
here in that Napa Valley right now my
son's turning six came at a rotten
Yountville at an insurance company
conference with National Life Group and
I want to send this message to you have
a killer week everybody love you buh bye